because they don't have an emotional
attachment they just look at chemical
compounds like Abba take a lack of tape
they don't go like oh that's weed or
that's heroin this bullet just invited
me to Benjamin dust dude yeah they just
no that's what they do they just they
just go oh you want me to make the
ptosis I'll make a megatosis
anybody a fan
of down under
I love Australia what do you mean I
[__] love it mate that's jumping to
conclusions so quickly I've never been I
always set it up like that great dude
you'll love it one of the most
underrated countries for senses of humor
in mind they're really funny yeah
they're pretty they have the best sense
of humor right there yeah uh one of
their political parties uh known as the
greens
ah uh call for a regulated legalized
cocaine industry in order to push
criminals out of business I don't know
about that one yeah I kind of like it
you don't like regulating uh the MJ
business does that cook green there's
cocaine oh cocaine specifically cocaine
regulating cocaine so they'll prom who's
their main business is it Colombian
sneaking over or they have like native
like Coke makers
why is it got to be Colombians no no
because they're they're pretty good I
think if it's Colombians I don't think
they're gonna give a [__] what's legal
or not they're gonna keep coming in oh
well I also don't think they're gonna
give a [__] who's paying them as long as
they're getting paid
so whether it's like a criminal organ
organization or it's government money
it's still money right I think the idea
is that uh they realize that the War on
Drugs they're saying the War on Drugs
doesn't work no matter what if you
failed it on every continent no matter
what it's going to be used so the only
people are actually benefiting from the
business of it are criminals and drug
dealers true whereas if you just
Legalize It Again people are going to
use it anyway yeah then there's at least
some other concept of like tax earnings
infrastructure business opportunity and
like something you know what I'm saying
I think there's a case for it I'm not
saying I Anthony promote the idea of
people using [__] cocaine even though
it's fun conceptually I never tried it
one of the things I'm better than you
one of the things that kind of failed in
the states though is because so wheat is
legal but because there's so many
[__] taxes on it it ends up being
hella expensive so yeah Black Market is
still thriving because people rather
just buy it it still exists however
getting weed legally is still always
better because it's even better quality
it's just better great you know what I'm
saying they tell you a warning label
that you're gonna die from cancer and
their wholesale is Black Market because
there's the supply just doesn't meet
demand and then the Peace of Mind of
knowing that you got it legally too
versus like the idea of trying to like
get it on the street in some way or
being caught with it is like also told
me what I'm saying is the psychology
changes but what they're really trying
to change doesn't really change you mean
like the the stopping the uses the
morality of it yeah like
um yeah because it's still the black
market is still thriving they're trying
to crush Black Market black Market's
still thriving yeah and then consumers
are still
but still taking it they're it's not
reducing I mean I'm not really I'm not
against weed right but the but if I were
to be if like regulating it I would
argue that the THC content that they
have now is dramatically crazier than
what's out naturally naturally I think
it's around three to four percent THC
that's way more engineered now yeah we
engineered it to the point where it's
like 40 THC so so whatever the yeah but
now they're coming out with studies of
like
um early onset schizophrenia yeah like
because the potency is so hot oh not
safe yeah so then like it's like more of
a hallucinogenic because it's so [__]
crazy like like that's what they say
about like uh weed Vapes like it's it's
too much weed in one hit it is too much
weed it's like you're taking a dab every
time and then people when they start
vaping they just they can't stop hitting
it and then they become schizophrenic
the size of oranges do when I was a kid
oranges was like this big and now all of
a sudden they're like as big as Nick's
head also when you're a kid you was like
this big
foreign
they're very good the Sumo mandarins oh
it's real I bet you just made that up
yeah they're big they're like this big
energy what about the uh one of the case
in point kind of like conversations as
well is the idea that uh again alcohol
it's hard for some people to perceive it
as a drug but the concept of it it is a
drug for sure I mean even caffeine's a
drug yeah so they talk about how at the
end of the day no matter what alcohol
still kills more people per year the
then even cocaine or like these hard
drugs if the jam is across the street
from a really big liquor store in our
area
and every time you just look across like
out in the open you just realize like
[__] we got in the wrong business
because that [__] place is filled up
all day every people are waiting at the
door before they open and they're trying
to pull the door like uh uh like and you
see the same people bro you see regulars
every single day like you can it's it's
faster even if you go to like 7-Eleven
you know that got those like little shot
glasses that people just come in you
gotta get like four of them and they're
just like damn you start your day off
that's right
I'm inspired
and even with prohibition that didn't
work it just gave hella money to the
gangs and that's when the mafia got
hella Ball but that's what I'm saying
isn't that also kind of a an exact case
study for this so it's like you make it
illegal and then it just thrives still
that thrives even more yeah in a
criminal space but if you make it legal
then it's still gonna Thrive yeah yeah
the government gets the benefit from it
I think Australia should try it out I
think they should be the guinea pigs be
a test somewhere at least it's not here
yeah you guys figure it out you see how
it works and then you you report back
yeah because I'm wondering if like well
there's certain countries right that
don't have a drug problem but they're
doing all right so like let's say
Scandinavian countries it's legal
whatever but they don't have a
population that's hooked on Heroin or
anything I feel like we can't trust them
dude I feel like they're standing aliens
well as far as like what their [__] just
doesn't apply to our country you know
what I mean no yeah the stuff that works
over there is like that shouldn't go
work over here well it's because there's
like 30 000 people there that's what I
mean yeah so I mean they're all happy
yeah they're mostly White yeah a lot of
Asian countries like like Japan South
Korea I mean Singapore has some crazy
laws but they don't have the same kind
of drug problems that we do because you
die if you get caught I think it's
really hard to compare countries because
that's like America going like man how
do we get our students to do homework
because in Asian countries they love it
yeah it's like you just can't you just
gotta knock it up so I'm wondering if
there's something that is cultural then
because it sounds like a cultural
difference yeah where like they drink a
lot they drink way more than we do they
smoke more than we do so maybe that's
their thing that's socially accepted
because like I guess what's socially
accepted here is like you dabbled in
drugs in college
and then you play around and like party
and like go to raids and [__] like that
they don't have that to scale out there
like they do have Raves and stuff like
that but it's like super taboo we just
have better Raves I think so but
everything because Europe's the same way
it's the I think it's the same culture
where it's like you get [__] up on all
kinds of experimental [__] yeah it's got
some good rapes right yeah we also talk
about like how drugs have become like
scarily lethal here and again they're
not like fentanyl like the idea of it
and the cases I've been seeing some
[__] Odeon fentanyl that shit's
crazy dude even people who don't know
they're taking fentanyl it's just laced
with fentanyl but we happen you know
we're like one of those [__] like
shitty news channels that has to look up
like Hey we're not shitty dude so we
we're not shitty my bad we're not a news
channel can we edit that out
but that being said you know what I mean
it's not like to say that every [__]
cocaine dealer it has to be like oh my
god there might be fennel here but just
the idea again you should think about it
though right if you're a coke dealer
don't you be like we should we should
figure out if there's fentanyl in our
product yeah if I'm right above the
middle man I should definitely double
check that or I'm putting fentanyl in to
make more money but the point is I heard
some people say it some people think
it's China
China's putting fentanyl in our cocaine
China's producing it but they're selling
it to Mexico and then they they work
together oh really facts that's a good
that's a good combination I have no idea
but facts they've been working together
a lot right there's like Chinese drug
lords in Mexico and [__] there's like
it's there's been one guy who got caught
with like [__] millions and millions
of dollars just all up in like different
bedrooms just stacked up yeah Chinese
meth dealer China makes everything oh
feijo Lopez yeah
majority of the
oh [__] they make everything
do they make most of our Pharmaceuticals
too because they don't have an emotional
attachment they just look at chemical
compounds like Abba take a lack of tape
they don't go like oh that's weed or
that's heroin
dude yeah they just no that's what they
do they just they just go oh you want me
to make the
ptosis I'll make a megatosis you know
and they just [__] everything is just
manufacturing they don't have and our
scientists are so emotional about it
yeah oh we're making [__] weed that's
not good that's bad I'm so emotionally
comforted it is it is cultural I think
though it's the same as like if if you
turn drugs loose in a city where people
had a higher depression rate versus
where everyone was happy already like if
like you know the difference when a
happy person is on coke and then where a
guy with closeted [__] depression is
on cook oh and then what's the
experience what's the difference uh
one's objectively sexier the other one
is just the depressed guy beautiful yeah
because even when they drink they're
like that exactly yeah yeah some people
they drink and then pouring everything
out and like oh damn you're sad this
whole time right that's why when you
when people eat corn to societal
collapse it decide the society was
already unhealthy to receive it yeah
it's like Hawthorne versus Irvine yeah
like things happen differently just and
they're like minutes away that's true so
true and in Irvine there are a lot of
kids using drugs all [__] exactly
farting UCI but they're not but they
still graduate it's not [__] not
[__] movies made smoking hella cool
and they made cocaine hella sexy I don't
care what you say it did the the powder
on the mirror power in the mirror
right guys in suits yep [__]
everywhere Studio 54. yeah all that [__]
scene it's like super cool you get the
best business ideas too when you're
doing coke with your buds but yeah it's
it's the same thing when when you think
of just even like two colleges like
there's a lot of kids that are taking
drugs in order to excel in school how
whack is that
Denzel can [__] fly planes using Coke
yeah I mean but that's why that's what
I'm saying look like when I watch uh
like the Dare campaign and like this is
your brain there's your brain on drugs
that [__] was so corny because like
during that time like Boogie Nights is
out
that looks way cooler way cooler like
you can't I'm sorry like this like
having something yeah but having some
like voiceover overactor that you paid
like four hundred dollars to like and
he's like has this commanding like this
is your brain does your brain on drugs
don't don't I sound like I'm really
trying to convince you instead of
[__] Boogie Nights it's just like
cool like you just see people doing cool
[__] and I'm like I would way rather you
think those ads need to be darker they
need they should have shown the flip
side of after Boogie Nights now they're
like [__] like the I think one
smoking commercial that did work was the
old lady that had the little oh yeah so
what's the cocaine equipment is it like
like why would you do fried eggs no show
Skid Row I got with no teeth yeah dude
yeah have you guys been seeing those
guys [__] leaning off fentanyl or
whatever the [__] they're they all look
like zombies going like this and [__]
show that [__] I personally hate
nosebleeds so I don't think the meth not
even once campaign oh yeah yeah yeah
they just showed a bunch of mug shots of
people who in their first arrest and
then they're like ninth arrest yeah oh
that was what it looks like yeah well
meth has never been sexy uh portrayed
either right that's not it's no it's not
unless it's Breaking Bad Breaking Bad is
probably the sexiest well making meth
with sections but they judge the users
right the whole time like like Walter's
like don't we don't use it actually I I
think that's the problems like even if
you watch Boogie Nights to completion
and you see that [__] falls off the
rails and everybody's lives get [__]
up yeah you still wish you had the past
of having done it and then looking back
and going I remember those days I mean
it's like you still want to do it you
don't want to do it forever high level
Glory guys is what's better the way up
or like um the feeling of the way down
what do you think I think I think most
people just want to be part of the story
yeah it's not even that they want to do
drugs it's like I did it too they just
want to be included when shit's high and
then yeah oh that's true it's like when
things are trending right and everyone
wants to get in on it exactly I'm doing
the ice bucket challenge for 12 views
but you're helping nobody watches me but
I'm in I'm I'm watching I'm involved
because I remember at high school I was
like oh you do Coke that's the weird
people [__] and then you hit your meth
pipe yeah that was trending at the time
I just wanted to be part of it you do a
little PCP
[Music]
foreign